so evergrand is this uh sprawling giant
of a real estate developer
as recently as 2016 it was the largest
real estate developer in china by sales
everground is also the world's most
indebted developer
the firm has more than 300 billion in
liabilities and it may actually be on
the hook for more debt which isn't
necessarily revealed on its balance
sheet
evergrande once one of china's most
successful developers has struggled to
pay its debt for months and its
liquidity scares unsettled the global
markets it's been a vulnerable week for
evergrand to say the least you know
recently there has been too much bad
news surrounding this name
[Applause]
the battle for survival is intensifying
in december everground failed to pay two
dollar bond coupons and was officially
declared a defaulter for the first time
evergrant is prepared to enter a formal
debt restructuring process which would
be one of china's largest and most
complex
china evergrand is beijing's biggest
worry right now it's not just about
evergrand it's the spillover into the
rest of the property sector and to the
economy more broadly
this final resolution for evergrass is
just getting started it really marks the
end of an old chapter the start of a new
chapter for china
[Music]
the chairman mr hue he came from really
stark poverty he was born in the late
1950s in hunan province which is a major
rural sort of agricultural province in
the middle of china
so
and all he wanted to do was to get out
of his village
he did that by getting into universities
he went to college he studied metallurgy
then in the late 1990s he started
evergreen got into real estate
development and then the two decades
after that he built it into this
gigantic real estate company
over the past two decades to have been
particularly savvy about how he's
expanded his business aligning his
investments and his growth and expansion
into property along with the agenda of
authorities
he was able to grow the company so
quickly and so into such a tremendous
size because in the background china's
economy was booming china was trying to
make room for hundreds of millions of
people moving from the countryside into
the cities
that was feeling a boom in demand for
property for homes for apartments
at the same time
as a result of the financial crisis in
2008 china introduced this massive
stimulus package that flooded the
economy with money and made
lending very easy very cheap the company
was able to translate some of its land
holdings use that as collateral for
loans to then help it get control of
more land and then to get more loans and
sort of it was a cycle that went like
that
through massive borrowing today
evergrande has become a sprawling
conglomerate that controls land five
times the size of manhattan and owns
more than 1300 real estate projects in
280 cities
it has businesses in a new energy
vehicles and historically also has
invested in football companies and even
bottled water
but as chinese president xi jinping
began to control financial risks in the
country's economy huay's debt-field
expansion strategy was called into
question
starting in late 2015-16 there was this
greater emphasis on curbing the amount
of debt in the chinese system by lots of
different measurements there is a
tremendous amount of debt in china it's
not just the amount of debt that china
has it's the pace at which it's
accumulated that debt
there is a real concern if chinese
companies borrow a lot of money and
build bridges to nowhere roads that
people don't use
homes that no one wants to live in
then that money is wasted and when they
have to pay it back there's not going to
be any money there to pay it back with
and
that is going to admire the economy
a big part of the debt problem lies in
china's real estate sector which
accounts for about 30 percent of the
country's dollar-denominated bonds
to curb reckless borrowing in 2020
chinese authorities drafted three red
lines metrics regarding debt that
developers will have to meet if they
want to borrow more
in september 2020 evergrand faced a
liquidity scare and people were very
concerned about a credit crunch at the
firm that was because a group of
strategic investors had the option to
seek repayment
investors simply weren't clear about
whether evergram would be able to honor
those obligations
evergrand turned to the government and
said look we are in serious crisis mode
here if we don't get out of this it's
going to have a huge ripple effect on
the whole sector do you really want that
to happen
and that really focused the attention of
the people who could help them in this
case it was the suppliers and they
waived their right to be repaid because
they wanted to ensure that evergrand
survived
that was just a very short-term solution
it didn't really get to the heart of the
issue which is that evergren's debts
were arguably becoming unmanageable
evergrand later denied sending a letter
to the guangdong government in which it
warned of a liquidity crisis and in
march 2021 the company outlined a plan
to cut its debt
but just months later concerns over the
company's financial health resurfaced
sending some of its bond prices to
record lows and its credit ratings were
repeatedly downgraded
we've consistently traded evergreen vans
during the last
nine months i'd say it was a bad
investment for us because you know we
ended up losing money not as much as
others because you know we start by
being short to begin with
the losses were not significant
investing in in chinese probably is it's
complex because you depend a lot on
government policies and it's very
difficult for investors to make a call
on those policies
the firm itself has more than 300
billion in liabilities now that includes
something of like 19 billion dollars of
bonds that are owed to offshore or
global investors as well as about 8
billion
worth of domestic bonds that are owed to
local investors in mainland china
evergrande is also said to have private
placements which are essentially hidden
or sort of opaque types of debt that
have been sold to just a small group of
investors
scrambling to repay its mounting debt
the company sold some assets and hue was
also asked by the government to use his
personal wealth to pay debt
but none of this offered a quick fix
if you just looked at the numbers the
the amount of debt that evergrand had
and you looked at how much money was on
the books you could tell there was going
to be
some trouble
over 1.5 million home buyers have partly
paid for evergrand properties but those
apartments are not yet built
in september 2021 over a hundred home
buyers in guangzhou staged a protest
demanding that the company restart the
halted construction work
missed payments on 40 billion one of
wealth products sold by evergrand to
retail investors also sparked nationwide
demonstrations
protests like these put pressure on
beijing to intervene and avoid further
unrest
chinese regulators summoned way and
rebuked evergrand for its debt problems
evergreen has said it is committed to
completing the project it also says it's
committed to repaying the wealth
investors
but the jury is still out on that
[Music]
historically way has been seen to have
the support of authorities partly
because of his contribution to broader
national efforts so things like building
more projects and helping boost gdp
however given the crackdown that we've
seen
across china particularly focus on some
billionaires it did become clearer that
huay may not necessarily be able to rely
on authority's support in the way that
he had in the past
the crackdown on property really figures
into that broader theme so the emphasis
that property is not for speculation but
is for living in has sort of been a
mantra that we've heard time and time
again
hui has also relied on a group of
friends sometimes referred to his poker
pals so that includes uh property mogul
joseph lau over the past few months it's
also apparent that some of hue's wealthy
friends have since headed for the exit
so selling stakes in the company for
instance and selling shares it does look
like the crisis that evergrande is
facing is really distinct from previous
episodes
mr hue he was
by any account a success story but that
narrative has changed quite tremendously
after holding out for months and meeting
debt obligations at the last minute
evergrand finally defaulted in december
an inch closer to a debt restructuring
meanwhile the government of china's
central bank signaled that beijing will
not bail out evergrand
this is a market event
it should be handled
in a market-oriented way based on law
so evergrande hasn't been particularly
communicative through this crisis
however it did release a statement
saying that it intends to actively
engage with creditors and it also
acknowledges that it may struggle to
meet some of its debt obligations
the provincial government of heinen
decided quite recently that evergrand's
projects on their site was not proper
was illegal they didn't have the right
permits and so they've ordered evergrand
to demolish dozens of of concrete condos
they were just about ready
just the image of this wrecking ball
coming for these condos which are almost
complete is sort of a metaphor for
what's going on immigrant right now the
wrecking ball is coming
hna the other debt-ridden chinese
conglomerate might offer a potential
model for evergrand
local government in hainan where hna was
based essentially took control of the
company sold its assets paid off some of
its debt and is still working on the
rest
the guangdong government now has sent a
team to go in evergrand and help manage
this crisis
some people think that the government
may ultimately take control of the
company now that's still very much up
for debate
in terms of what happens to mr hui could
it be something similar to chen fung the
founder chairman ceo of h a it's hard to
say
mr chong was detained arrested charged
with illegal activities
i'm sure that if some misconduct is
revealed the regulators are not going to
be shy about looking to pin
responsibility on those behind those
decisions
apart from evergrand more than a dozen
chinese developers have defaulted some
are worried that the credit crisis in
china's real estate sector might spread
damaging the country's financial system
and even the world economy
but chinese authorities have repeatedly
said the risk is controllable and it
would not undermine the market in the
medium and long run
many many chinese families have much of
their wealth invested in their apartment
and so if you saw a big decline on that
you could see people
one losing a lot of their consumption
power but two also people potentially
going onto the street and protesting and
being really upset so that that was a
major concern for the government
to support the slowing economy the
government released a tremendous amount
of liquidity and cut borrowing costs
it also urged banks to boost real estate
lending and eased a key debt restriction
for developers there are certainly some
investors that will probably never touch
a chinese bond again and investors will
need to have
some more level of certainty on the
rules of the game before they start
investing again
so china's developers are now facing a
reckoning of swords they have to shape
up their financial health and reduce
their leverage if they're to continue
and prosper
from
when mr hui started evergreen back in
the late 90s
until now you could do really well in
china
by just sort of building on top of debt
that model is really coming to an end
china's changing to something new
something we don't really understand
quite yet but what is certain is that
the old way china used to work is over
[Music]
you